yeah we have breaking news mark SP is
cutting its rating on the European
Union's supernatural credit to a double
a from Double A plus so I'm got the the
statement open right here SP analysts
are saying we've reassessed our opinion
of cohesion within the EU which we now
consider to be a neutral rather than a
positive rating factor that said the
outlook is stable but SP Scarlett Oliver
cutting its rating its superin a chiral
EU rating to double-a from double-a plus
it says reflect our opinion that under
most scenarios including a UK withdrawal
from future though not current budgetary
commitments our anchor ratings on the EU
will remain at the current level of AAA
minus plus one so this is interesting
especially in light of the fact that you
had two different ratings companies also
downgrade to their assessments of the UK
following the brexit vote too yeah
exactly i guess the outlook here is
stable but still a pretty big cut of
course you've got the UK getting cut we
had that from Moody's we also had it so
there's two totals there then we had in
this cut today it kind of brings up this
point that listen even though markets
here signaling a bit of recovery that
there's still so many questions that are
lingering out there and you have to also
think about what kind of events could
potentially be on the horizon that could
roil markets and make people revisit the
seriousness and the nature of this
entire situation things that won't be
known for years probably because of
revenue forecasting long-term capital
planning any adjustments all these
issues that still need to be resolved
right